yeah aside from the panel how how else
was your guys's con experience yeah i
did yeah it was good yeah i mean the
signing was freaking awesome yeah like
you know that that was a good thing you
know at least like everyone who came to
the signing was super nice super
respectful you know lots of like really
cool artists and stuff like that i just
like kind of wish i had enough time to
like go to the artist alley because i
feel
mcn's artist alley was like really
freaking good compared to like other
cons that i've been to because like you
know
naturally when you're at a signing a lot
of people bring up stuff that they
bought oh yeah
some of the stuff i was genuinely like
where the hell did you get that yeah
because i want to get it but
unfortunately we didn't have enough time
to go to the artist alley this year so
that was a little disappointing but yeah
you know well it's kind of hard to walk
around in general this year i feel like
because i feel like the last convention
we went to we was like ax 2019 and we've
said that you know we could still walk
around the convention right yeah like we
could you know we'd get stopped every
now and again you know especially at
a you know at a event like ax but it was
it wasn't to the point where it
completely stopped your movement and
like made it so you couldn't walk around
yeah and i felt like that was
very very different this year yeah like
i i didn't even bother trying especially
after i heard what connor tried to do oh
my god
i knew you're going to [ __ ] tell me
we got it we've got it
so funny it's so funny so like
after the panel and after our signing
was it after the signing it was after
the signing okay so after that like our
day was free and we had like a good two
three hours to enjoy the convention we
were like up in the green room right now
yeah yeah yeah we're we're so we're up
in the green room normally at this point
we're just like great we've got two
three hours to enjoy the convention
let's just walk around and stuff like
that but like seeing how many people
were at our signing and seeing how many
people couldn't even make it to our
signing because the signing got cut off
uh the line was like full capacity like
an hour or two even before we even
started the sliding i'm like yeah i
thought about everyone who wanted the
signature uh yeah yeah sorry
we would have done it if we could have
yeah we would have done it if there was
enough time yeah yeah i think we were
signing for like two and a half hours
and we
just
and that was like capping the line two
hours before
the line even opened yeah um but yeah so
i i got the feeling that probably not a
good idea to walk around especially
without security and uh conor was just
like guys i got this i got the perfect
disguise so
so let me tell you what connor's
disguise was his disguise was a to wear
a face mask like a normal covert like a
surgical face mask and some sunglasses
and a hat
this is genius this is actually so so
first things first wearing a sun wearing
sunglasses inside totally inconspicuous
no one's going to look at you at all why
would you we weren't we wearing
sunglasses inside a second thing he
forgot that the shirt he was wearing was
a trash taste shirt that hasn't been
released yet no yeah it was a trash
taster that the general that hasn't been
shipped out to the general public yet so
also it's the trash taster that you see
him wear in almost every video and every
episode so it's like
like that shirt has just been like
synonymous with like yep that's kind of
[ __ ] i you know i just uh
i wanted to say hi to some of my friends
so i was like hey i'll just come quickly
and say hi i was i wasn't going to stay
out long i'm just gonna go say hi and
yeah obviously i knew it wasn't a
foolproof disguise i was i wasn't
[ __ ] going to film any any movie
scenes fooling anybody right like i was
just like maybe it'll just buy me enough
time where people will double glance and
then when you walk away yeah right and
so and how far did you get well no so i
went to meet my friend who i told to
come meet me uh at this like at the gate
so it was like i literally walked out
like two meters and then my friend was
problem was that at this area that was
really convenient for me uh like people
were waiting for sydney yeah yeah
science sydney stuff and obviously
people like were waiting around there
and recognized so yeah people just
started coming up to you right away but
i was trying to talk to my friends and
it was really [ __ ] annoying because i
was just like hold on a second i'm just
talking to my friend give me a moment
and then they were like just asking for
photos and then the moment i turned
around to like go back there was like
like five people this side and then
because my friend left who i was talking
to yeah people just filled the void and
i was like oh [ __ ] i'm getting
surrounded
so so the people in front of me i just
quickly took a picture with them and i
was like make this fast please please
and then the people behind me i could
just feel them be like comment and i was
like i've got to go i got to go i'm so
sorry i got it because i because if i
start doing all of them i i i won't yeah
i won't i won't stop and it sucks it's
like i have to go yeah like i'm sorry
that i wasn't able to give you a picture
that is the most like suffering from
success story ever
but it sucks right because it's like
it's
people friends would be like oh come
hang out i'm over here i'm like i'm i'm
sorry like i can't i can't walk there
yeah and they're like oh wow okay you're
too big i'm like literally yes like
i i actually can't walk to you like
this will be a miserable experience
like it's literally not even us trying
to like humble brag it's just like no no
no it was just like this was like the
eye-opening weekend for us to be
to for us to see like oh okay now we we
have to consider things that we've never
had to consider don't get me wrong we're
greatly appreciative we're very grateful
we [ __ ] love it but yeah you know i
mean like because uh after a signing i
really really wanted to go to sydney's
panel right because her panel wasn't on
the main stage it was on like one of
like the side stages that was like in
the middle of the convention it was like
it was kind of like a two or three
minute walk yeah yeah yeah so it was
like a two three minute walk through
like this crowd and i remember asking
one of the handlers like can i go see
sydney's panel because it was our first
panel i'm like i i want to i want to see
my girl man where's my girl where's my
girl and they were like
i don't think that's a good idea you
should not be walking through that crowd
right like they literally were just like
no
after what has happened on stage we
cannot stop you but we highly highly and
they're not like begging me please don't
go because i could see like the sweat
drop on her face like being like oh i
don't like if he says yes i can't deny
him but yeah i don't want to deal with
like the consequence of right
actually like so on the second day right
so on on the sunday uh we were hanging
out at uh like that one of the bars it
was like the nov hotel which is like far
enough from the convention that you know
it's like not too many people there but
close enough that you could walk to and
from the convention right right so i was
hanging out there with a few of my mates
on like the sunday and it was like
everyone was still in the convention so
it was like pretty dead and so you guys
had your signings so i wanted to meet
you guys in like the green room or
whatever
and so
once the con ends your guys are signing
in so i'm like great let's go meet up
and i said okay i'll go to i'll go to
the hotel that we were staying at which
is on the like which we had to go to the
other side of the convention and i
remember going out with my mate to see
the optimal path right to walk to the
hotel that we're going to and what it
felt like i walk outside and everyone
started to go outside to like the big
grassy area because the convention is
over now so you just see like this
massive crowd and what it felt like is
you know like in that [ __ ] zombie
movie whether on the like the roof
they're on like the roof of the mall and
they have to get like the food and they
see like the crowd of zombies that i
have to walk through it's literally like
the opening scene to death right
that's what it felt like because i'm
just like okay let me let me plan on my
route what's the like the most optimal
route i can uh i can i can walk without
like what's the least possibility i can
grab the bench
[Applause]
i mean you know like a lot of things
happened this weekend but uh i think all
in all it was a positive experience i'd
say it was cool and weird having
bodyguards we got bodyguards on the last
stage oh yeah yeah yeah
what happened on uh saturday which is
the main panel and gone getting shot by
a nerf gun and stuff yeah yeah yeah they
kind of were like all right i uh we will
step this up a lot and then they went
like
props to them
with like four [ __ ] body cards
without so i felt excessive but i i
appreciate it yeah uh had a really nice
guy who would just it was really chill
and it would speak to me and then it was
really strange going into the toilet and
just coming out of the toilet and he's
just like waiting for me and i'm like
okay this is weird but it makes sense it
was cool you know i he was he was very
professional i i see why you know people
don't mind having one because you know i
thought it was going to be really
overbearing having someone like behind
you yeah yeah but he was really nice he
just kind of like stood back and uh
whenever he felt anything was happening
he'd just kind of introduce himself or
not just kind of step up a little bit
yeah yeah it was really good i mean it
was nice i mean definitely we
learned that we have to get it now for
yeah
ax and like future conventions that
we're going to uh yeah i mean this like
like i said this is like our first
convention since
starting trash taste and now we know
this is like set the president's
precedence
president that wasn't that word's really
given you a little trouble it is it is
it is president mr president set the
standard for us yeah
i mean i still had a great time actually
um that was awesome like yeah everyone
was super nice like getting to
see people after so long has been like
crazy
yeah just reminding you that
great people exist yeah man you know
just like seeing everyone seeing like
the gifts that we've been given yeah as
well so many [ __ ] talented artists
and stuff as well yeah yeah yeah i think
my favorite gift that uh was given like
to all of us actually was there was this
like wooden
there was this wooden trash taste plaque
and it was like perfectly crafted i'm
just like there was such great
craftsmanships on it i'm like oh this is
like this looks amazing and i remember
like gaurping at it with joey and just
like we were just like admiring like the
craftsmanship and then we're like we
turn it around and he says my balls
just like he got he got gone
someone gave me these cards and i found
them in my pocket earlier and one that
just says ham on lord of striking
thunder oh yeah this is your cards right
yeah i don't know i don't know there's
hamon and yugioh yeah there is yeah why
is the hammer on in yugioh i don't know
this one is raviol lord of phantasms i
didn't really understand why that one
was relevant to me
i think harmon is my one actually what's
up
yeah the [ __ ] yeah i was given hamilton
i want ham on dude
someone just gave me a yugioh car i
don't know i mean i just i had it in my
pocket i think i think they gave one for
garn as well but it must be in the bag
of stuff yeah yeah so wow that's cool
yeah so uh yeah thank you to everyone
who showed up and like gave gifts and
you know signing and the panel and all
that it was yeah it was really really
cool